peut être utile est empathique comment
rester pertinent
comment ne pas être opportuniste façon
générale il ya eu une belle retenu des
annonceurs sauf que les messages sont
très respectueux si le plus important
jamais consommé non là c'est le
déclencheur qui nous a donné vraiment
envie d'avancer avec cette campagne
c'est le moment où on s'exile savez des
entrepreneurs dit qu'ils vont inviter
les consommateurs à acheter le produit
d'un autre entreprenante si on peux pas
serrer la main et on peut s'aider
l'écologie marc fortin est à l'origine
de certains des messages qui ont marqué
les esprits au début de cette crise y
compris certaines des annonces
gouvernementales
conçu pour refléter le discours des
autorités publiques
nous vivons une crise majeure et pour
qu'on s'en sorte
on doit se protéger et respecter toutes
les consignes
[Musique]
on s'apprêtait à faire une porte ouverte
hier qu'ils avaient toutes un plan de
communication avec des divisions avec
l'achat média des tournages et tous les
confinements arrive la première chose
que tu fais c'est ton plan de marche
invest craquer complètement
on a pris deux fois télé on the two
belle on en a fait 5 ou de tourner au
taux de justement de cette importance et
le temps d'appeler hinault nos parents
nos grands parents la pandémie a
bouleversé l'industrie de la publicité
et ce sont les grandes agences avec un
large éventail de clients qui ont le
mieux traversé la crise jusqu'à
maintenant
les agences qui sont infectés
directement et de façon importante quand
ils sont exposés dans des agences
complètement à l'arrêt tourisme ce qu'on
appelle en anglais hospitalité les
hôtels les restaurants
tous ces éléments là c'est un gros gros
gros coup de frein parallèlement il ya
d'autres agences qui se représentent des
clients du commerce de détail de
proximité épiceries dépanneurs pharmacie
qui eux vont se retrouver un peu moins
touchées avertissement cette publicité a
été tourné avant le contexte actuel et
contient des scènes qui serait interdite
aujourd'hui dans certains cas les
agences québécoises ont réussi a
simplement modifié certains contenus
sans avoir à refaire complètement leur
campagne sur le web puis à la télé maxi
ben oui je pense qu'en bout de ligne
l'avertissement qui disait aux gens que
le message que vous voyez respectait pas
les normes parce que on le fait avant je
pense à participer à son succès on
n'entend plus de 2 millions de vues avec
ça puis après ça bon le mieux à la télé
d'autres annonceurs comme la banque
nationale ont choisi d'offrir
gracieusement leur temps d'antenne à des
organismes sociaux youtube bénéfice de
relations publiques derrière ce mais
dans des cas comme une pandémie mondiale
la première chose à qui on pense même
comme publicitaire ou comme annonceurs
c'est assez proche
l'industrie de la publicité canadienne
aurait connu une baisse de revenus de
l'ordre de 25% jusqu'à maintenant ce
n'est pas terminé
si on reste confinée encore pendant
plusieurs mois il ya des business qui ne
connaissent pas des rats lancement qui
sont littéralement fermé
parfois lorsqu'on est en crise
économique en annonçant davantage on est
capable de relancer une marque une
entreprise scellés fermés on peut pour
la relancer c'est dramatique pour
certaines agences qui ont pas su se
diversifier au cours des dernières
années
pour cet ex publicistes et professeur de
marketing
la crise sanitaire force tous les
acteurs à s'adapter
les consommateurs souhaitent de plus en
plus acheter des produits locaux et les
entreprises doivent démontrer une
volonté d'être de bons citoyens
corporatifs qui est intéressant avec la
période qu'on vit présentement c'est que
les marques peuvent démontrer leur côté
leurs valeurs propres à leur côté humain
et ça c'est hyper important
la situation évolue d'heure en heure les
annonceurs constate par ailleurs une
augmentation des taux d' écoute des
médias traditionnels
ce qui ne passe pas inaperçu bien
entendu la raison pour laquelle
présentement à la fois les agences mais
également plusieurs annonceurs
s'engagent à faire un effort particulier
pour soutenir les lots nos habitudes
vont avoir été modifiée ben forcément ça
va transformer nos façons de de faire
transporter de façon de vivre simplement
il faut déjà anticipé à quoi ça va
ressembler la vie après le déconfinement
qui même après la la pandémie c'est dans
quel état d'esprit les gens vont être
dans 3 2 non du coup aujourd'hui les
agences de publicité ont déjà modifié
leur façon de tourner pour respecter les
normes de la santé publique
cette industrie fragilisé toujours à
l'affût des changements s'avère encore
et toujours un miroir révélateur de
notre société
[Musique]